i'll give you the quick background which
is the building item it has a billboard
on top of it which which after moving in
i got tired of pulling up every day and
seeing other attorneys on top of my
building so
i contacted billboard company and uh we
did a quick you know your
run-of-the-mill
attorney billboard which is on top of my
building as we speak
so i have a billboard on top of my
building and then i got a better rate if
i got a couple other billboards which i
did um and they were just your run in
the mail billboards you know win-win-win
a million awards a gazillion dollars
recovered those type of billboards which
i don't think anyone pays any attention
to
and so then i got an even better
discount if i got more billboards which
i did and they were just about to go up
when i thought you want to know what why
am i putting a billboard that looks like
every other billboard
that doesn't say anything to anyone
that you know a lot of people actually
have
become
a little bit
of a contempt against some of these
billboards because they see them
everywhere and there's usually a picture
of a smug looking guy like me
and you know some
some accolade about himself for herself
and i thought you know how about i do
something different
the world as it is right now is
is depressing we get bad news every day
so why not throw something up that's
going to make people
either give them a chuckle
let them think about something or what i
thought would happen is no one would
even bother to read it but i guess i was
wrong people do read billboards
the billboard question is the it says uh
were you injured while searching for
dead bodies at lake mead demand
compensation
which to me is dripping with irony it
takes the uh idea of the
you know the greedy attorney mixed with
the
person who doesn't want to accept any
responsibility for anything they've done
we put it up there with the thought that
uh most people would get it it's it's
you're supposed to look at it and
chuckle however some people did see it
and they it confirmed every suspicion
they have about attorneys which is look
at this guy
he's going after the you know
the last shred of dignity here he's
chasing every buck he can he's the uh
the saul goodman
of las vegas
and uh the joke is kind of on them
because that was kind of the point was
to
take a
take somewhat of a meme of
a
of an attorney the uh
classical greedy attorney and kind of
flip it on its head to say hey not not
all attorneys are
this way some actually have a sense of
humor
and
i think when people realize that
they they get an even larger chuckle out
of it so that was the point
another billboard i have up now is
call your
call your congressman and demand the mtv
play music
i'm an 80s kid
i grew up on mtv and uh it's one of
those things that i i i thought was
amusing and funny is that you know mtv
doesn't play music
actually sad
uh there's another billboard if you're a
fan of saturday night live which i
certainly am
um it's uh fellas do we need more
cowbell
most people won't get it but those who
do
are kind of in on the joke we have a
vanilla ice quote
if you got a problem you'll all solve it
um i was never a huge vanilla ice fan
but i did happen to catch him opening up
her m.c hammer at the thomas and mack
back in the i don't know it was probably
1990-91
i like that one
another one is a quote from iron mike
tyson a man i love and respect as to
many people everyone has a plan until
they get punched in the face which is a
very deep and true quote and i really i
really love that quote to the folks that
are laughing you're my people you get it
the folks that
aren't
laughing please do
it's it's a uh
it is a
ironic view on attorneys and i hope you
get a laugh out of it that was the point
not there to uh upset you with you know
greedy attorneys it's actually that
that's that's the entire point of the of
the uh billboard there is to
show you that hey man we're not all
like that in fact most most of us aren't